well india was one of the countries to
first propose a suspension on vaccine
patents and it's now
also the country most in need of help in
fighting
the pandemic on thursday that reported
more than four hundred thousand nukovit
19 cases and almost 4 000 deaths setting
records for both the burden on the
country's hospitals is becoming
increasingly unsustainable
it's all hands on deck with even medical
students now being called in
to lend a hand
running low on sleep junior doctor rohan
aghawal dresses in protective gear
to begin a 27-hour long shift
he's only 26 years old and hasn't even
finished his medical training
what job we are assigned is what is to
be decided by god
whom to be saved whom not to be saved
and we are not made for that we are just
humans
and at this point of time we are being
told to do this
so it's really a depressing atmosphere
and i just
want a break there is a severe shortage
of oxygen
and ventilators at this hospital and
others across delhi
many people come looking for a bed for a
sick relative
but these are also in very short supply
patients and relatives crowd every
available space
in some cases people lie close enough
for patients to touch
one man is in a storage room surrounded
by bins
of medical waste rohan says the sounds
of his workplace
haunt his sleep that beep sound is
continuously in her head
even while we are sleeping that b b b b
that casualty noise the icy noise that
continuously goes in our head in our
ears
every time every day patients rush from
hospital to hospital
hoping to find someone who will admit
them many are turned away
left to die on the street
oxygen supplies are transported by armed
guard
and crematoriums work around the clock
my parents keep asking me what happened
how was your day i tried to be very
positive because i can't tell
them all this negativity i can't like
take this negativity with me at my home
i try to be very positive
after 27 hours in the er rohan
agave says he could sleep for two days
but a friend with a sick father calls
rohan agrees to help knowing that in
reality
there's not much he can do
let's go to pune in india now where i'm
joined by vinita val she's an
immunologist at the india institute of
science education and education and
research the government is saying that
the second wave is
linked to a double mutant variant first
discovered in march
how much evidence is there for this
there is loose evidence uh it is
discovered in march but it was in
existence
at least from january the
sequencing wasn't done in enough in time
and that is why
tracing back its origin in terms of
which month it arrived on the scene
is difficult to say and all the data
related to
sequencing of the viruses is on a small
scale but there is
enough circumstantial evidence to say
that this particular
double mutant variant it has its own
name now
uh b1.617 that is
probably contributing and i can't say
it's a cause and effect relationship
but this association is pretty strong
and that is probably causing the way but
it's not
present all over the country and still
the wave
is there in other parts as well so
india together with south africa has led
the proposals for a waiver on
vaccine uh patents how significant would
such a
waiver be for india in the shirt in the
short and in the long term
uh it's in principle this is a good idea
that in an emergency situation like this
the patent should not be
the hurdles for manufacture however if
you look at india
and the capacity to produce vaccines
that is highly inadequate even current
bharat biotech
manufacturers or serum institute the
biggest manufacturer in the world
are not capable of producing enough
doses of whatever they know of
sufficient to guarantee vaccination for
every individual
in india so even if there is this
assurance and hence there is a
technology transfer
i still feel there will be a long lag
before
the vaccine production done locally will
be
available for a mass vaccination so i
think the only solution right now
is importing wherever the vaccines
are and in sufficient numbers
long term of course it will be useful uh
so
india's government top scientific
advisor yesterday warned that a
third wave could be on the way does that
mean india has already seen the peak of
the second wave you think
i wouldn't draw that inference from the
statement by scientific advisors
they we are certainly climbing up as
even your reporter said
there are 400 000 plus cases even
reported yesterday and today
so the wave so to say is still
going up and up i don't know when we
will reach the peak
but i suspect we are close to reaching a
peak
but some states are already going down
in numbers others are coming up
however what the scientific advisors
have said is
quite correct i don't know when but
there will be another wave and possibly
another wave because there is
uh not enough vaccination coverage
within
india and vaccines are reasonable
guarantee but not 100 percent guarantee
that they will protect from the next
round of infection especially the
variant infection
so we have to worry about it we have to
anticipate
third way we have to increase and
strengthen the
medical infrastructure about which
everybody is talking and we are really
in the pathetic stage
but i don't think we are already at the
top
of the so-called
this way whichever number it takes
anita thank you very much for taking the
time to
talk to the uw news thank you
thank you and now to some other
developments in the pandemic
indonesia is banning travel during the
popular homecoming period to celebrate
aid outfitter covet 19 cases there have
been
falling but the government wants to
prevent a repeat of last year's spike in
the death
after that holiday the world health
organization is planning to set up a
global pandemic hub
in the german capital berlin to gather
and analyze data
on emerging pandemic threats canada
has authorized use of the biotech pfizer
vaccine on children as young as 12.
it's the first country in the world to
approve a vaccine for children
you